i saw headlines okay  i saw don king talking in all the media  saying oh i'm all good with mike tyson  man we've worked it all out and you know  what i thought when i heard that  i thought man that's great news i love  to hear it but i'll believe it when i  hear it from mike oh absolutely i have i  can't  afford to be angry anybody give that  energy away man  we're not going to be here that long you  know i want to give you energy to  something powerful that's going to come  back and return  so she did communicate with don king and  and uh  just everything yeah it was beautiful  dude i love it okay great beautiful  because that's what i realized um once  you start experiencing  love you have to experience forgiveness  self-forgiveness  and you go to hope you know i mean  lineage and forgiveness in different  parts of life and then you realize that  um  at the end of the day we're dead it's  over right  that's true man yeah  dude